[Music]
sarah's with us in denver hey sarah
welcome to the ramsay show
sarah
hi there dave sorry about that thank you
so much for having me how can we help hi
there john
um yeah so i've just started the
financial peace university which has
been great so far i've
surpassed step baby step one and i'm on
baby step two
and my question um sorry here in a row
but uh my question is
um
this the dead snowball
um i'm having a hard time reconciling
that only because i'm dealing with
a couple of uh factors being that i have
seven credit cards
at zero percent interest
and what's the balance
the total balance is going to be
somewhere around
gosh off the top of my head maybe
15 k and what's your household income
income is about 82. okay and what do you
do for a living
i just started as a software engineer so
i just switched curves so now i'm
actually able to manage
uh my finances
great question that a software engineer
would ask so that's perfect
so here's the here's what we have
figured out because i would have asked
the same question on financial
background
and it didn't because the debt
snowball's not mathematically correct
when you pay off smallest to largest
regardless of interest rate that's not
mathematically correct mathematically
correct would be to pay off the highest
interest rate first
the avalanche right
well yeah that's what other people
started calling it years after the debt
snowball was famous some character came
up with the avalanche but
anyway but the uh the the concept
doesn't work
with the avalanche and the reason it
doesn't work is personal finance is more
behavior
than it is math it's 80 behavior 20
head knowledge
if you try to fix a behavior problem
with math you're going to struggle but
you can fix math with a behavior change
and so the reason i'm telling you all
that is that the human
heart needs to see
traction in your world we'd call it
gamified
so the debt snowball is gamified you're
gamifying yourself when you pay off the
little one regardless of the interest
rate
you're have accomplished a portion a
tiny little portion an incremental goal
that gives you hope that this is
actually going to freaking work then
when you pay off the next one you go a
little bit more excitement when you pay
off the next one you get a little bit
more excitement when you pay off about
four or five of these things or six of
these things and this snowball starts to
roll regardless of the interest rates
you get so stinking excited and
believing and hope-filled
and you you get blinders on and you
start sacrificing deeper and
your progress accelerates and the
probability of getting out of debt and
the speed of which you get out of debt
is even better with the debt snowball
even though it's mathematically
incorrect
and there's been several studies
actually done that prove that by the way
yeah i mean i think the biggest thing
for me is that my student debt has been
the absolute bane of my existence yeah
what you're going to get rid of
you make plenty of money it's going away
it's all going away and i kind of want
it hanging out there to just keep that
fire going i want you to stay pissed off
at it but get just get really mad at
this whole thing and go all right i'm
sweeping these mosquitoes under the
sweeping these mosquitoes aside these
stupid little credit cards so i can just
draw back and punch this student loan in
the nose baby i'm going to smack it
it gets visceral
and when you can kind of get that stuff
going and instead of you getting
instead of trying to mathematically
analyze this that's when you're going to
have more success and that's coming from
a guy who's a math nerd
and your math got you seven credit cards
to begin with
seven
and student loans you were trying to win
the zero percent game and you
lost
one of the best predictors of future
behavior is your past not always but
it's a good it's a good baseline
you've tried the math game and it hasn't
worked oh so just try something
different try ourselves try something
different yeah i mean if some if a year
from now you're worse off than you were
then change and ramsey was crazy yeah
there you go you have to get in line on
that one but yes you're right right
you know what i mean like it's it's i
hear people at the beginning of the year
call you know
calling my show about losing weight or
fixing their marriage and well this year
we're just we're going to go back to our
workout do something different yeah it's
not worked change the recipe different
keep getting chocolate cake i didn't
want chocolate cake change the recipe
change it man change the recipe
something different do something
different doing the same thing over and
over again you can do it
do something different definition of
insanity